Climbers attempting to summit Mount Everest
and stand on the top of the world have their
work cut out from them.
Dangers are everywhere on the long climb,
there’s risk of extreme altitude sickness,
unpredictable winds, and freezing weather.
There’s also the threat of avalanches - great,
unstoppable tidal waves of snow that can bury
a person alive in seconds or strand them,
leaving them to freeze to death, cold and
alone.
It’s a sad reality that not everyone that
visits Everest comes back down again, and
rarely does a climbing season go by that the
mountain doesn’t claim yet another victim.
Situated on the border between China and Nepal,
in a sub-range of the Himalayas of Tibet,
Everest is one of the Seven Wonders of the
Natural World.
With an elevation of 29,031 feet - or 8,848
meters.
Mount Everest has attracted many experienced
mountain climbers over the decades.
But even for the most experienced mountaineers,
the ascension up its snowy slopes is far from
easy.
Deaths occurring on Mount Everest are nothing
new and hundreds of people are believed to
have died attempting to ascend the treacherous
peak.
Sadly, due to the risks involved with carrying
heavy loads down off the mountain, many of
those who die on Everest are doomed to stay
there forever, their frozen bodies serving
as their own grave markers.
It’s difficult enough to move your own body
up and down Everest, and in many situations,
bringing a body back down is simply impossible.
The bodies of these lost souls are scattered
all across, and sometimes underneath, the
surface of Mount Everest.
But some of those bodies are different from
the others, and have a special name within
the files of the SCP-Foundation.
They call them SCP-5140.
SCP-5140 is the designation given to a number
of frozen bodies which are found all across
Everest.
It is unclear exactly how many instances of
SCP-5140 there are, though some estimates
have placed the number at somewhere between
one and two hundred.
At present, it is unknown if all the instances
of SCP-5140 are dead bodies belonging to climbers
who met tragedy on the tallest mountain in
the world, or if some of them are something
else entirely.
But while their origin is unclear, if you
come in contact with a 5140 instance, there
won’t be any doubt that it’s different
from the normal body of a dead climber.
That’s because SCP-5140 corpses are a lot
like vampires in some ways.
That isn’t to say that they actually are
vampires, they certainly are not undead and
cannot function after death.
But, much like a vampire traditionally drains
blood to survive, these bodies drain heat.
SCP-5140 corpses are ectoentropic, meaning
that they do not adhere to the normal laws
of thermodynamics.
Whenever these cadavers are exposed to sources
of heat, including human body heat, the corpse
will instantly drain the source of any and
all thermal energy.
However, the temperature of these SCP-5140
bodies remains the same, regardless of how
much heat they are able to drain, staying
at a consistent fifty degrees Fahrenheit,
or ten degrees Celsius.
Should any living person come into direct
contact with one of the SCP-5140 corpses,
the body will absorb their natural body heat,
bringing their victim’s own temperature
down to ten degrees celsius, and causing them
to die.
And once they have died, their body then becomes
a new instance of SCP-5140.
As a quick side note, this might feel vaguely
reminiscent of another anomaly, which features
seemingly inert dead bodies that are hazardous
to anyone around them: SCP-2316.
This anomaly is a powerful memetic hazard
consisting of a large number of drowned human
corpses.
These corpses are extremely hazardous to approach
at even a considerable distance, as the memetic
hazard inherent to the anomaly causes those
affected to recognize the bodies in the water
as people they know - particularly from their
childhood.
Like a siren’s call, victims are lured into
the water, believing that the familiar bodies
are calling to them.
If the victims aren’t stopped, quarantined,
and given amnestic treatment, they are essentially
considered lost.
They will walk into the water, and be absorbed
into the collective, becoming just another
body floating in the water.
While the Foundation doesn’t currently believe
that there is any official connection between
the two anomalies, the similarities are undeniable,
and worth taking into consideration.
Moving on.
At present, it is unclear whether SCP-5140
corpses are caused by some sort of infection
or parasite that spreads among the bodies
uncovered at Mount Everest.
If this is the case, the Foundation has yet
to uncover the “patient zero”, the root
cause of these infected bodies.
There is also little to determine why a deceased
body requires the absorption of heat, as well
as how it achieves this and also keeps its
own temperature low but not frozen.
Given that interacting with an instance of
SCP-5140 can be fatal, it does seem that these
anomalous properties can be passed through
contact and exposure, like a disease or parasite.
But there have been no observed anomalous
effects among any living person visiting Mount
Everest.
There is a possibility that the SCP-5140 corpses
have developed some form of posthumous mutation
that has come as a result of being killed
during an Everest avalanche and buried in
the snow, their bodies starved of heat after
death.
After all, Everest is known for its cold temperatures,
occasionally reaching as low as one degree
Fahrenheit, or minus seventeen degrees Celsius.
Not to mention the difference in air pressure
at such high altitudes, as well as frequent
high speed freezing cold winds.
At the summit of Mount Everest, wind speeds
can reach up to 280 kilometers per hour.
That is equivalent to 175 miles per hour,
and high speed winds have even been known
to catch mountain climbers off guard and send
them plummeting to their deaths.
Perhaps the combination of these conditions;
the freezing temperature, the air pressure
and the winds, have triggered some sort of
change in a number of the bodies unfortunate
enough to never leave the snow-covered slopes
of Mount Everest.
Either that, or these abandoned corpses left
in such extreme cold could be the perfect
home.
Maybe some form of unknown, and so far undetected
parasite is capable of inhabiting these frozen
bodies, and can spread to other living hosts
by draining them of their body heat.
Stranger things have certainly happened at
the SCP Foundation, and that could possibly
explain why anyone interacting with an SCP-5140
corpse meets the same grisly fate.
Regardless of what causes these abnormalities,
or why the SCP 5140 bodies have only been
uncovered at Mount Everest, close contact
with the corpses often results in casualties
and fatalities.
Naturally, this is a cost the SCP Foundation
likes to avoid as often as it can.
The nasty habit SCP-5140 corpses have of draining
a person’s body heat makes it impractical
to bring them back to a Foundation research
facility for testing - as does the fact they’re
on the tallest mountain in the world.
Instead, MTF-Delta-14 have been tasked with
keeping these heat-thirsty cadavers contained
to Mount Everest.
Mobile Task Force Delta Fourteen, also known
under the code name “Winter Wonderland”,
is formed of a group of particularly adept
mountaineers, and experts in understanding
and adapting to particularly brutal terrain
without drawing attention to themselves.
These covert operatives are tasked with periodically
climbing Mount Everest, and keeping SCP-5140
contained.
It is this team’s job to locate any new
instances of SCP-5140 bodies and bury them
in the snow.
In doing so, the goal is to prevent any unwitting
mountain climbers from stumbling upon one
of these bodies and potentially becoming a
new instance themselves.
Meanwhile, the Foundation is pushing for both
Nepal and Tibet to tighten restrictions on
climbing permits.
But of course, the money that Mount Everest
tourism brings to these two countries has
likely impeded this.
According to the Foundation’s file on SCP-5140,
an incident occurred during one of Mobile
Task Force Delta Fourteen’s annual Everest
expeditions.
Members of MTF Deta-14 had been traversing
towards the Everest summit, encountering more
and more of the SCP-5140 bodies as they made
their way up the mountain.
Just as they were instructed to do, the team
buried each of the frozen corpses they came
across under a blanket of the snow.
The Delta Fourteens noticed though, that there
had been a much higher number of the frosty
cadavers on this mission, speculating that
perhaps Mount Everest’s high winds had blown
the snow off ones they had already buried
on previous missions.
One of the Delta Fourteens, a man named Charlie
Smith, was in correspondence with his colleagues
at their basecamp.
Charlie reported that one of his fellow Winter
Wonderlanders, Patrick, had touched one of
the SCP 5140 corpses when the team reached
the summit, and that he was now buried according
to protocols after becoming a 5140 instance
himself.
As they began their descent from atop Everest,
Charlie sent an urgent communication to basecamp,
reporting that he’d uncovered three more
SCP 5140 bodies at an abandoned campsite.
Except these three instances were different
from any he had encountered before.
These corpses were somehow still moving.
Attempting to hurry down the mountain, Charlie
reported that a mass of SCP-5140 corpses were
blocking his path, and draining another of
his squad mates, Arnold, of his body heat
to make him one of them.
Arnold had been carrying the team’s provisions,
including their oxygen reserves to combat
the lack of breathable air at Mount Everest’s
high altitude.
Charlie tried in vain to use his flare gun
to clear a path, hoping to distract the now-walking
cadavers with a heat source, but it had no
effect.
His final message to base camp warned the
rest of Delta Fourteen to not come to the
summit of Everest, with Charlie frantically
urging them to not let climbers anywhere near
it.
His final message stated simply that“The
Mountain is danger”.
A rescue division of Mobile Task Force Delta
Fourteen arrived just under two hours later,
tracking Charlie’s last known location via
a GPS beacon.
Strangely, despite the frantic messages from
Charlie, there were no signs of any SCP-5140
instances.
None of the piles of corpses he had warned
them about could be seen above the snow, and
certainly none of them were moving.
It wasn’t long before the rescue team found
Charlie though.
He was dead but not drained of heat or turned
into another instance of SCP-5140.
No, sadly after bringing their fallen comrade
back to base, an autopsy revealed that Charlie
had likely died the same way so many other
climbers on Everest had, he had suffocated
from a lack of oxygen.
Further examination of his gear revealed that
Charlie Charlie’s oxygen intake valve had
been damaged earlier while the squad had been
climbing to the summit of Mount Everest.
His teammates, Arnold Hillary and Patrick
Edmund were also discovered on the mountain,
but only Patrick had been turned into an SCP-5140
instance.
Arnold had simply died from exposure, just
like Charlie.
The rescue team concluded that, due to lack
of adequate oxygen, Charlie Smith had hallucinated
the sight of SCP-5140 corpses moving and blocking
his path, spending his final moments in terror
as the mountain’s conditions slowly killed
him.
The Foundation is still unsure exactly what
causes bodies to become instances of SCP-5140,
or even how many of them are on Everest, but
a major and troubling development has recently
been made.
After an increase in global temperatures led
to a large avalanche that resulted in a large
portion of the mountain that had previously
been covered in thick snow being exposed,
the Foundation sent planes that were equipped
with thermal imaging equipment to scan the
mountain.
What they found was as confusing as it was
terrifying.
The SCP-5140 corpses aren’t just spread
across the surface of Mount Everest, they
are much of Everest.
The mountain itself is a huge pile of corpses,
just waiting to drain the life from anyone
who attempts to scale it and turn them into
a permanent part of the peak.
So if you were planning a trip to the Himalayas,
hoping to scratch “climb Mount Everest”
off of your bucket list, maybe give it a pass.
Otherwise you might find that the climb is
even colder than you were expecting.
Now check out “SCP-1861 - The Crew of the
HMS Wintersheimer” and “SCP-3082 - Neverland's
Lost Boys and Girls” for more mind-boggling
mysteries from the SCP Foundation!